c'est vous qui le dites et les
commémorations du 11 novembre
un siècle après vous en pensez quoi on
vous donne la parole bonjour valérie
nous pouvons vous êtes professeur des
écoles une tablette est une provocation
pour vous le centenaire de l'armistice
ça vous inspire quoi
en tant que directrice et professeur des
écoles je dirais que le centenaire de
l'armistice ça m'inspire tous d'avoir un
devoir de mémoire pour tous nos élèves
[Musique]
créent leur vie de ta votre place
maintenant
[Musique]
pour madame la directrice le clap
c'est quoi votre prénom la mairie allait
valérie on y va le centenaire de
l'armistice ça vous inspire quoi
tout d'abord ça n'inspire mon grand père
mes deux grands pères mais un tout
particulièrement c'est gabriel mathurin
qui était au 164e régiment d'infanterie
du respect du respect pour tous ces
jeunes qui ont combattu ils sont partis
la fleur au fusil pour quelques mois et
qui ont passé quatre ans d'enfer ça
m'inspire tous les morts qui aiment les
eaux les horreurs ils ont fait des
recherches sur les événements sur les
différents acteurs de la première guerre
mondiale
mais nous sommes allés aussi étudié au
monument aux morts de son nom c'est pour
vous est-ce important cette
commémoration un siècle après c'est
important pour le devoir de mémoire
oui pour qu'on se souvenir bête et tous
ceux qui sont morts pour la france c'est
important de commémorer tous les
armistices chaque guerre a laissé à la
fois son tribut de souffrance mais nous
a apporté la liberté et la paix donc il
est important que les générations soient
conscientes et d'ailleurs même les
adultes que la paix elle seule elle se
conquiert parfois les généraux allemands
et alliés se sont réunis ce jour là
savez vous
oui ça c'est une question pour pour le
prof
ils se sont réunis dans un wagon dans la
dans la forêt de compiègne à retombe les
jours j'ai quoi ceux-ci neil armstrong a
mis fin à la guerre qu'est-ce suivante
quelle leçon faut-il tirer de ce conflit
mondial il n'y a eu la création de
l'europe et l'europe si elle n'est
absolument pas parfaite dans plein de
domaines
elle a au moins amener la paix en 1918
tout moment où ça s'est terminé
tous nos anciens avaient dit c'est la
der des der on s'arrêtera là il pourra
plus y avoir de guerre aussi or il y en
a eu une seconde
et puis qu actuellement il ya des
conflits qui se déroule un petit peu
partout donc il faut que nous nous
rendions compte que la guerre nous
menace continuellement merci à vous je
crois que ça s'est bien passé finalement
je suis pas sûr pour quelqu'un qui a eu
peur j'étais cours
[Musique]